- This is Oshi, a toco toucan,
the largest and most recognizable
of the toucan family.
They are found throughout
Southern and Central America.
While their habitat is extensive,
their population has continued to decline
over the last decade.
Their appearance is striking,
with its iconic bill
that covers almost 50%
of its body surface area.
It looks heavy but is
actually rather light.
They use their bill to pluck
out of reach fruits from trees.
Toco toucans are considered
extremely gregarious
and social birds, living in flocks.
The pet trade and the
destruction of their rainforests
are the main cause for
decreasing population.
This is the toco toucan.